Hoy vamos a sacar las primeras conclusiones de lo que está siendo este primer Mundial de Clubes
tras completarse una fase de grupos de la que además vamos a hacer nuestro 11 Ideal.
Ha habido mucho debate sobre el Mundial de Clubes desde el inicio, creo que ahora que ya se ha
disputado la mitad del torneo, que ya sabemos lo mejor y lo peor, que ya sabemos lo que más nos
gusta y lo que menos, es un buen momento para hacer un poco de balance tanto de lo competitivo
como de lo futbolístico que al menos nos está dejando esta primera edición. Para arrancar,
una pregunta para saber un poquito cómo respiramos. Exactamente, nota al campeonato con todo,
englobamos todo a este primer Mundial de Clubes con lo que estamos viendo en esta fase de grupos.
Nahuel, ¿qué nota le pondrías? Yo le pongo un 7. Vale, Adri, yo bajo al 6. Tú, Alex de Llano. Yo
estoy muy cerca del 9. 9. Voy a decir un 9. Ostras, un 9. Es que me está gustando mucho. Es muy proclivia
que a Alex le guste mucho, seguramente es de los que más disfruta fútbol con mebol, fútbol también
africano, asiático y evidentemente vivir un Mundial de Clubes, pues en ese sentido es una bacanal
para nuestro Alejandro de Llano, ya que no se puede pegar otro tipo de bacanal. El fútbol nunca falla.
El fútbol nunca te abandona. Esta es una lección para todos vosotros, pizarritas. Yo le pondría un
7. Estoy de acuerdo con la nota que le ha puesto Nahuel. Me parece un torneo, una competición que
está siendo notable, que tiene puntos fuertes, que tiene cosas que mejorar. Sí, yo creo que tienen
bastantes que mejorar. Pero sabiendo los condicionantes y el contexto, me está gustando
más incluso de lo que estaba. Pero mira, Miguel, un pequeño apunte. Fíjate que uno de los puntos que
más se comentaba para tirar un poquito por tierra Mundial de Clubes era ¿Pero cómo va a jugar el
Oakland City? Y el Oakland City ha hecho más puntos que muchos equipos que han conseguido su pase y
de hecho, claro, tú vete a preguntar ahora. Claro, tú vete ahora a los alrededores de la Bombonera
preguntar por Christian Grey. No va a ser el de las sombras. Sin embargo, alrededor del monumental
igual se termina haciendo una estatua. Claro, tal cual. Se llama Christian Grey. O sea, acabo de caer.
Es que es duro. La sombra del empate es alargada. A ver, vamos a ir primero dejando conclusiones
del formato, estructura, sede, competición y luego pasamos al departivo y cerramos con el 11
ideal que hemos diseñado de la fase de grupos. En cuanto al torneo, tú me decías, Nahuel,
que te parece un buen torneo. Sí. El formato sobre todo porque transmite la sensación de
Mundial de Verdad. Sí, es un mundial y con todo lo que ello engloba, con estampas que yo creo que
no hemos en cualquier otro tipo de competición. Hemos visto aficionados de él, Huidad de Casablanca,
Esperanza de Tunís, Times Square, Fluminense, Palmeiras. Pero bueno, fondos enteros de aficionados
que han ido a apoyar a su club. Bueno, por supuesto Boca y River. Por cierto, me hizo
mucha gracia saber realizado un vídeo de una aficionada de River que empieza a insultar como
si no hubiera un mañana a Chalanoglu, mientras Chalanoglu está dando la típica vuelta de
reconocimiento al campo antes de jugar el último partido de la fase de grupos. Es un
mundial. Es un mundial y creo que eso está bien traído y que es replicable. Además,
con el formato de 32 equipos, que me parece el mejor formato posible para un torneo así.
Y creo que todo eso es muy positivo y hay que valorarlo. Yo estoy muy de acuerdo. 32 equipos,
el formato ni más ni tampoco menos. Y es verdad que se consigue la sensación de Mundial. Quizás,
con nuestro enfoque eurocentrista, lo vemos menos. Porque quizás los que menos folclore
aportamos somos los europeos también por un tema de distancia. Ojo, que ahora vamos a hablar de la
sede. Pero es verdad que vemos ese concepto de Mundial con equipos diferentes, con estilos
diferentes. Ver a Melody Sundowns en ese sentido es un soplo de aire fresco. Ver, evidentemente,
el colorido que aportan los sudamericanos. Yo sí que tengo, como dice el abuelo, esa sensación
de Mundial. Me gusta lo que expone el abuelo. Y estoy de acuerdo también con él porque,
además, los continentes están representados. Antes hablaba Alex del caso de Oakland. Así que me gusta.
Me gusta. Y creo que el formato así está bien y no hay que tocar. ¿Os parece bien el reparto por
continentes? A mí sí. Me parece lo más justo. Sí que es verdad que... A ver, claro, si te pones a
decir cómo van no sé cuántos europeos y tan pocos de tan otro. Pero, bueno, al final es el peso que
tenga cada confederación y las posibilidades de representar cada una. A mí me parece interesante
el hecho de que podamos ver en futuras ediciones si se decide ampliar el formato. Porque yo me
imagino ampliar en cuanto a cupo. Me parecería... A mí eso ya... Yo te digo, a mí no me gustaría,
pero... No, no, conocemos a la FIFA. Vale. O sea, claro, hay que saber de quién hablamos. La FIFA ha hecho esto para sacar dinero, evidentemente.
Por eso hay que alabar lo que está bien hecho mientras esté bien hecho. Claro, claro. Pero todos sabemos qué collar tiene ese perro. Claro, pero... Y ojo,
que voy a decir una cosa, que igual también es impopular, que esto es una industria. Sí, claro. A mí me gusta el fútbol por otras cosas,
pero también entiendo que la gente que organiza el fútbol lo gestione de esa manera. Sí. A mí el problema
es cuando eso aprieta todavía más el calendario, que es una de las cosas evidentemente negativas,
y cuando se hace sin ton ni son. Necesitaba el fútbol... Estamos hablando sólo del mundial. Claro. Que luego lo tiene. Claro, exactamente.
¿Necesitaba el fútbol o un mundial de clubes? Bueno, yo creo que el mundialito era... El mundialito me sobraba. Es que...
De hecho... De eso no tenía ese sentido. Claro, claro. De hecho, yo creo que... Claro, al fin eso es una industria, todo el mundo quiere poner sus partidos,
pero la creación del mundial de clubes a mí me llevaría a plantearme eliminar lo que ahora quieren convertir... Absolutamente.
...la Copa Intercontinental. Entiendo. Sí, porque eso no... Claro, eso va cada año y esto es cada cuatro. Pero estoy completamente acuerdo.
Al final es un poco lo de... El paso de la Supercopa antigua a la Supercopa actual... Dices... Hay cosas que están mal de ese proceso.
Y a mí que se juegan a la DSOD, me gustan 3-0 y menos 10. Pero a nivel formato, a nivel fútbol... Ostras. Es una mejora.
Oye, y si hacemos la Supercopa cada cuatro años también... Ostras. Esto me gusta un poco. Pero... No, porque si propones esa idea,
lo que va a pasar es que va a haber Supercopa cada año y luego Super-Supercopa cada cuatro. Así que cuidado con las ideas que dan.
Cuidado, Nao. Cuidado, Nao. Oye, Nao, y si con el mundial de clubes cogemos una clasificación completa con todos los equipos...
Y el Super... ...los equipos pueden mucho partido. A mí hay una cosa que me gusta del mundial de clubes es que no cuenta los títulos conseguidos en Juegos Olímpicos como estrella.
¡Nooo!
Bueno, yo estoy viendo muchas clasificaciones hablando de campeones del mundo de clubes y se han metido todos los formatos que ha habido.
Sí, sí. Ha habido, si por haber, organizados por la FIFA. Así que menos lobos que a Perucita.
Venga, venga. Miguel, ahora vas y vuelves. Yo tuve la oportunidad de ir a un mundial de clubes en 2018 con el formato anterior y vamos.
Ni la mitad de la mitad de la mitad del ambiente que hay en este. Y mira que en aquel fue River que sí que llevó bastante gente, etc. Pero vamos, es que ni se le acerca.
Ojo, que al mundial de clubes le falta historia, le falta el recuerdo...
Ganar prestigio.
Le falta el prestigio, le falta los precedentes, ¿no? Que el día de mañana Boca vuelva a irse a Oakland y vas con él, ¿sabes? Eso es lo que mola el mundial de clubes.
Nowell tiene esa historia abierta, Uruguay, con gana. Dices ¿en qué momento va a haber esa rivalidad? Bueno, pues con los partidos. Eso le falta al mundial de clubes, pero eso no se puede ganar en la primera edición.
Otra cosa que me has dicho, Nowell, y estoy muy de acuerdo, es que Estados Unidos está empeorando el torneo.
Creo que muchas de las críticas que recibe el mundial de clubes realmente las recibe por la sede, no por lo que es el concepto del mundial.
Es todo muy artificial. Ya no es un país que tenga poca cultura futbolística, no son las críticas de Sudáfrica 2010, por ejemplo.
Es que es la sensación de que vas a Estados Unidos y te tienes que adaptar a Estados Unidos, ¿no?
Y las presentaciones estas que no tienen ningún tipo de sentido, la cuenta atrás antes del pitido...
Oye, yo entiendo que somos a veces un poco inmovilistas, los aficionados al fútbol, pero...
Pero a veces lo somos con razón.
Claro, claro. A mí todo esto me sobra bastante. Luego podemos entrar también en el tema de los partidos en pleno verano a puro rayo de sol.
Dobles cooling breaks. Es que eso es muy importante. Porque hay una cosa que no se puede cambiar.
Esto se mete. Es un input a un calendario ya super sobresaturado.
Entonces, ¿qué tienes que hacer? Pues intentar que las condiciones favorezcan al desarrollo del fútbol en vez de perjudicarlo a unos jugadores que ya están fatigados, cansados...
Y hay una solución bastante sencilla para el tema calor, temperaturas y demás.
Está tendiendo FIFA a dar mucho protagonismo a hemisferio norte.
Ya sea con el tema de países árabes, tenemos el tema de Marrocos, Portugal, España con el mundial del 30...
Oye, dar el mundial de clubes a Ases del lado sur y juegas en invierno.
Júralo entre Argentina y Uruguay que a mí me hubiese encantado. Creo que ahí sí que hay un...
Es un margen de mejora importante. Creo que además a corto plazo pensando en el mundial de selecciones del próximo verano.
Creo que la FIFA debe tomar nota y ver qué va a tener. Y lo de las tormentas, chicos.
Lo de las tormentas para mí es lo más preocupante. Obviamente las temperaturas, pero creo que siempre se han jugado mundiales con altas temperaturas.
Sí, pero...
Pero el tema de los retrasos, etc.
Pero es algo que tienes que cuidar incluso más porque Luis Enrique se ha quejado los dos partidos que ha ganado.
Cosa que me gusta mucho. Que las quejas vengan en las victorias.
Se ha quejado del calor y del terreno. Y es verdad. Eso hay que cuidarlo.
O sea, si ya tienes a jugadores que están en un tramo complicado de la temporada...
Ostras, no me metas en una sede con 35 hogares.
Primero por el soldado de los jugadores. Claro.
Primero por ellos. Y luego por el espectáculo.
Exactamente.
Dicho lo cual, hay una cosa que me gusta del calendario.
Que es que favorece, Adri, la igualdad entre confederaciones.
Si el mundial de clubes estuviese en diciembre, creo que la diferencia entre UEFA y Conmebol...
El caso es botafogo. Clarísimo. Vamos.
Claro. Es que les pillaba muy mal antes.
Y creo que puestos a fastidiar a alguien, pues yo creo aquí en una especie de discriminación positiva, fastidia al que tenga más pasta que es a la UEFA.
Sí. A los europeos que van a llegar reventados después de su temporada pero que lo va a igualar.
Es un pequeño handicap.
Sí, sí. Y yo lo compro, eh. Me parece bien.
Y además, el otro día lo recocía Sabegroso directamente.
Que decía que muchos eurocentristas llegábamos con el prisma de...
Bueno, seguro que Europa va a dominar este torneo.
Y los sudamericanos, el resto de confederaciones, no van a tener nada que hacer.
Y fíjate que bien lo están igualando aprovechando, primero, el ritmo competitivo que llevan.
Y segundo, la voluntad y el querer hacer algo importante en este torneo.
A la verdad, a mí me gustaría, estoy de acuerdo con la reflexión, pero hay una discriminación bastante negativa que es el tema del dinero por participar que se le da a cada club.
Mira, otro bueno.
Que al final parece sangue alante. O sea...
¿Crees que debería ser igualitario?
Sí, sí. Es que que gane diez veces menos el representante de Doce Anías respecto a los top de Europa.
O sea, quieres crear un torneo lo más igualado posible.
Intentáis equipar también un poquito más los precios.
Sé que es una utopía, sé que es el país de la piruleta, pero está mal y hay que decirlo.
Aquí hablaba también la FIFA.
Y no creo que sea la motivación principal, pero puedo comparar un poco el argumento.
Que es que podrías, metiendo tanto dinero...
Imagínate que hace un trabajo increíble...
Bueno, es que a O'Clan City es muy complicado.
Pero River Plate. 90 millones en el mercado River Plate.
Desigualas mucho la Liga Argentina.
No creo que sea la motivación principal.
Al final acaba repercutiendo el bien de la Liga.
Porque ese dinero River lo va a invertir en fichar a los mejores jugadores de la Liga.
Sí, pero te lo digo porque esto es uno de los problemas que tiene la Champions.
La Champions, justo.
Que el Bate Goryshov se mete en Champions, se mete en Champions, y luego no hay competitividad en Bielorrusia.
Pero, que insisto, que no me apetezca el argumento.
Pero cuando se da, es verdad que puede tener cierta lógica.
Pasando un poquito más a lo deportivo, Alex, me parece que en este Mundial de Clubes...
Más o menos lo imaginábamos y teorizábamos.
Pero es verdad que en la práctica se ha visto.
Como hay tan poquito tiempo, creo que ha vuelto a poner de manifiesto que es imposible hacer reset entre temporada y Mundial.
Lo hemos visto con Boca.
Lo hemos visto con Porto.
Lo hemos visto con el Atlético de Madrid.
El City está haciendo una muy buena imagen y el Real Madrid está creciendo.
Pero bueno, ambas cuestiones es porque uno ha fichado mucho y el otro ha fichado bastante y ha cambiado de entrenador.
Pero lo que voy es que un equipo sin grandes cambios no tiene tiempo suficiente de vacaciones para hacer reset.
Porque hay equipos que necesitan un mes y medio de vacaciones, su pretemporada y que sin muchos cambios mejoran inmediatamente.
Sí, mira que Boca lo intentó con el cambio a Miguel Ángel Russo, pero no tuvo el impacto deseado.
Obviamente también hemos visto mejora en Boca.
Hay que decirlo que lo que venía con Errol y Gago a lo que ha sido...
Ha quedado muy feo lo de Oakland, pero es verdad que el partido contra Benfica y la competitividad con Bayern...
Estuvo ganando los dos partidos en el minuto 83.
O sea, han sido esos minutos finales que le han condenado.
Pero sí que, para mí el caso más pragmático es el del Oporto.
Creo que es la representación clara de lo que es no ser capaz de generar un reset.
Porque ha llegado Gabri Beiga, tenías un jugador que había terminado bien la temporada como Rodrigo Mora.
La oportunidad de extender un poquito lo de Samu.
Y Ángel me ha sido incapaz y de hecho ya ha derivado en su despido.
Pero sí que es bastante evidente que sobre todo a los equipos europeos les pilla un poco.
Esto qué es. Esto es la temporada anterior.
La próxima jugó la camiseta de la temporada que viene.
Pero las estadísticas me la están contando para los goles de esta temporada.
O sea, están un poco ahí metidos en ese lío.
Y ahí yo creo que es donde están pescando sobre todo los brasileños.
Oye, un apunte sobre lo que dice Alex.
Me parece positivo que no hacerlo bien en el Mundial de Clubes traiga consecuencias como el tema del despido a Anselmi.
Ha sonado también la destitución de Zubizarreta como director deportivo de Oporto.
El entrenador de Oakland, ¿eh?
Se lo van a desviar.
Sí, bueno, por lo que lo hemos comentado.
Pero el prestigio se lo da que tenga peso.
Claro. Que se tomen en serio.
Claro. Es que vuelve a ir a la Supercopa de España.
Se destituyó a Ernesto Valverde después de una Supercopa de España.
Y el Barça estaba líder de la liga.
Evidentemente no se destituye sólo por la Supercopa de España.
Por lo de Roma, por lo de Anfield. Bien.
Pero es una derrota en una Supercopa de España lo que te cambia eso.
Para mí eso es lo que le da valor a la competición.
Dentro de este tema del reset también está derivado el tema de los cupos y los clasificados.
Porque claro, nos hemos encontrado, por ejemplo, el Porto.
Yo lo explico siempre.
Realmente el equipo dominante en los últimos años en Portugal viene siendo el Esportivo de Portugal.
¿Qué sucede? Que en Europa, con Sergio Consisao, el Porto ha seguido metiéndose en octavos, metiéndose en cuartos, llegando muy lejos.
Y eso es lo que le ha clasificado.
Porque además la última temporada no cuenta.
La última temporada cuenta para el siguiente ciclo.
Ya me dijisteis hace bien poquito que vosotros los cupos no pasabais de dos máximo por equipo a tres.
Yo decía que sí, vosotros que no. No os planteo eso.
Por liga.
Por liga, perdona, sí.
Pero os planteo.
¿Creéis que debería ser ciclo de cuatro años pero contando esa última temporada aunque complique la logística?
Sí.
No.
Yo lo digo porque puede darse el caso.
Esto también lo debatíamos.
Imaginémonos que gana este año...
No voy a meter a la Barça porque si no en este país, Madrid y Barça, todo te posibilita.
Voy a meter al Liverpool.
Imaginaos que el Liverpool gana a Champions, que tampoco va a ver si es eso o no.
Imposible.
¿Gana el Liverpool a Champions y no va al Mundial de Cruella?
Ya sé que se clasifica para el que viene.
Pero es un poco contraintuitivo.
Porque oye, lo de la liga no importa.
Lo del Barça, el Napoli, eso no importa.
Digo esta Champions.
Pero que ganas la Champions y de repente los diez días te ibas a ir de vacaciones y estás en...
Paris Saint Germain.
A ver.
No, pero el Paris Saint Germain sabe desde que viene el club.
Ya, ya.
Yo sé que la logística es complicada y el ideal sería que hubiese dos semanas más de margen.
Claro.
Pero a mí me parece una motivación extra.
Si ganas la Champions ese año vas al Mundial de Clubes también.
Creo el jugador.
Yo creo que...
Con las primas que están...
Igual no lo ve ahora, lo ve después.
Yo digo, oye, Bastoni, saca el balón.
Que yo no voy a...
A mí me está apretando.
De verdad que no.
No quieren ganar la Champions para no ir al Mundial de Clubes.
Yo se ponía así de perfil con la chancleta y me decía...
Pasa.
Y yo decía ¿me vas a pegar?
Y decía no.
Y siempre cumplía la palabra.
Bueno, yo le haría esa a Bastoni.
¿Me vas a presionar?
No, no, no.
Tal.
Si yo total ya tengo pillado los vuelos y me voy a Ibiza.
Yo lo digo porque me ha resultado un poquito...
A mí me...
A ver, entiendo que resulta anticlimático.
Que es verdad que este año no se ha dado, pero que se podría dar la situación.
Pero bueno, es que no.
A ver, yo sí...
Mira.
Es un defecto de forma.
Te voy a dar un ejemplo.
La semana antes del Mundial de Clubes, Pyramids y Mamelody Sundowns...
...juegan la final de la Champions.
La ganó el Pyramids y jugó el Mamelody Sundowns.
Eso me suena un poquito...
Pero es que a mí, sinceramente, lo que me parece es que como ya está...
Todo el sorteo que se hizo en febrero o marzo por ahí...
Me parece complejo.
También puede ser condicional.
Sí, que sea.
Champions 1.
Claro.
Lo entiendo, sí.
Porque puede haber también... Fíjate la derivada.
Estoy pensando, dándome cuenta de que mi idea tampoco está buena.
Esto lo está escuchando alguien de un club de dentro.
De decir, claro, ponte tú a resuelvar el hotel.
Claro, claro.
De hecho, la mayor complicación no es el que gane.
Imaginémonos final Liverpool-Inter.
El Inter da igual que gane porque ya va a ir.
Pero estamos a la espera de que va el Liverpool.
Si el Liverpool no gana, igual tiene que ir al Red Bull-Sasburg.
O un equipo Premier.
Chelsea, por ejemplo.
Está esperando.
Sí que es verdad que puede haber cierta complicación.
Hay veces que no entendemos decisiones de los de arriba,
pero hay veces que las hacemos por algo.
A mí lo que me gusta es que aquí cuente lo de la Champions.
Me da igual el campeón de liga.
Cuente la Champions.
Al principio no estaba claro si la Champions,
coeficiente UEFA con la Europa League y tal.
Me parece bien que cuente la Champions, que sea un embudo.
Lo que hace es el Liga, te lleva Champions.
A mí eso me suena.
Y lo que hace es el Mundial de Clubes, el Mundial Planetario.
Habrá que competir contra Plutón, aunque ya no sea un planeta,
pero creo que lo han metido en el Mundial de Clubes.
Un poco como lo de Inter-Miami.
La liga más potente de fuera de Europa
y que creo que habría que empezar a llamar o a plantear…
La sexta grande.
Exactamente. Es Brasil.
Lo digo porque muchas veces se nos lleva la boca.
Uy, la Champions.
Es la sexta liga de Europa.
La segunda división española.
Esto se ha llegado a plantear.
Ya, pero en los dos casos son…
O sea, hay liga potentes.
Hay paja.
Quiero decir, está Portugal, está Holanda…
Claro, es que no tiene ningún sentido.
Claro, pero tú ves luego el nivel de inversión…
A ver si el Ajax en segunda división va a quedar a mi tabla.
No, pero ves la tabla de inversión
y muchas veces la Champions puede gastar más que la de la DVC.
Pero es que más que las dos gasta el brasileirado.
Y creo que, bueno, al menos…
Oye, una cosa buena del Mundial de Clubes
es que mira las confederaciones, mira los países.
Pues estamos viendo claramente que el domino de Brasil sobre Argentina,
que venimos viendo año a año, se ha vuelto a evidenciar,
que también los brasileños están más cerca de la élite.
Sobre todo porque a nivel físico, en cuanto a contexto,
Sudamérica son los que mejor preparados están.
Tienen un calendario… Eso sí que es un calendario asfixiante.
Flamengo, que no llegó… Los estaduales…
… a la final de la Copa Libertadores, disputó 78 partidos
los 12 meses previos antes de jugar un Mundial.
Pero los jugadores no juegan todos.
Ese datito trampita lo he visto yo también.
No, no, no. Cuidado.
El estadual…
Sí, muchas veces se va sin por…
Sí que es verdad que juegan jugadores suplentes.
Pero, vaya, quiero decir…
No vas a poner a los 11 a ver cuánto se queman.
Ya, ya.
Pero es que el recuento de partidos de los equipos europeos
sí que juegan 99 % de los partidos titulares.
Para mí la clave es que iguala todo y es un factor…
Oye, que me parece perfecto el fútbol brasileño,
pero Brasil tenía un mes entre diciembre y enero,
entre la competición, que son sus partidos,
más o menos la media de partidos de los que han jugado
los titulares de Flamengo en 2025 y los de PSG.
Los de PSG habían jugado 12 partidos más o menos
los de Flamengo.
A mí ese es el dato que…
Sí, pero bueno, porque ahora estás viendo que Flamengo
va a entrar en el tramo más decisivo de su temporada.
Claro. Es lo que hacemos antes, que todo lo iguala.
Todo lo iguala.
Y nada, al final estamos viendo un Flamengo
que está rasando en el campeonato local,
24 goles a favor, 4 en contra, líder del Brasileirao,
líder de su grupo en el Mundial de Clubes.
Para mí la sorpresa mayúscula ha sido Botafogo, porque…
No llegaba tan bien.
Claro, venía mejorando un poquito, pero las sensaciones eran raras.
Botafogo había tenido un principio de año en el que
se había ido Arthur Giorgi justo después de la Intercontinental,
habían llegado varios entrenadores interinos, etc.,
que no lo habían acabado de hacer bien.
Llega Renato Paiva, tampoco empieza demasiado suelto el tema
y ahora parece que se está todo encaminando,
después, sobre todo, también del triunfo frente a PSG.
Brasile al margen sí que creo que hay un gap
de diferencia considerable.
Es verdad que yo solo he visto muy, muy, muy flojos
al tema de Oakland, que aún es que es con empate,
al AIN…
Al AIN horrible.
Para mí el peor equipo del Mundial.
Muy flojo.
Luego los otros han podido más o menos competir.
Ya se ha metido Monterrey, se ha metido Miami…
Inter-Miami.
Inter-Miami, Miami.
Los Miami Inters.
Sí, sí, sí.
Por eso no sabías.
Ya me has comentado el partido en la tele.
El domingo.
Los Suárez-Luises.
Ahí hay un gap importante y diferente,
pero sí que también querría decir, Adri…
Los Maximilian Falcons.
Guau, guau.
Me apetece ver…
Seguir viendo la evolución de los equipos saudis,
que sabemos que tienen mucha pasta, que van a seguir invirtiendo
y Alilal me ha parecido competitivo.
Nosotros no lo seguimos, hacemos caso a Jimmy cuando nos lo cuentan,
pero, hombre, tenemos que comentarlo.
Sí, además, a mí me parecía un buen atractivo en este Mundial de clubes
con realmente estos equipos y si funcionan o no con las inversiones que hacen.
Dicho esto, claro, si te toca en un grupo, como le ha pasado a la Juve,
con Wydat y con Alain, estos dos equipos,
estos dos clubes que ganan el Mundial de este torneo
y que son un poquito huevitos, a veces nos confunden.
Pensábamos que la Juve quizá estaba para un poquito más.
Roto mucho ante el City.
Lo sé.
Eso puede tener trampa también.
Lo sé, lo sé, pero igual no era para tanto como estábamos viendo en el caso de la Juve.
Es difícil calibrar.
También hay equipos que están haciendo muchas pruebas.
El Bayern contra el Benfica puso muchos suplentes y palmón.
Y tipo son 11 diferente en la segunda jornada, respetada primera.
Claro, o sea, hay que entender que la fase de grupos, conclusiones las justas,
por eso hemos analizado lo del Real Madrid de forma tentativa.
Permíteme, Álex, porque nos estamos quedando ya sin tiempo
para dar el 11 ideal que hemos dibujado la fase de grupos,
sobre todo el dibujado tú, con alguna sugerencia.
Es Ustari en portería.
Sí.
Por delante de Bonu, que también ha estado realmente bien.
Porterazo Bonu.
Arraf, Yair, el de Botafogo.
Haussen y Ainurí en defensa.
Sí.
Acuña podría entrar en la derecha izquierda.
Teles, pero bueno, yo creo que ha sido un muy buen mundial de Ainurí hasta el momento.
Pone persecución a Adam Frisch.
En el centro del campo hemos situado un centro del campo de tres.
Además, creo que bastante acrónico.
Canónico.
Exactamente, con De Osa, con Jorginho y con Reinders.
Sí, Reinders yo creo que es uno de los nombres del mundial, ¿no?
Lo bien que está jugando desde su...
Claro, es que es muy bueno.
De Osa ha marcado un golazo contra Uragua, que igual está nominado hasta el Puskas.
Y a mí me está gustando.
Sobre todo los dos últimos partidos son muy buenos de Nelson de Osa.
Y arriba del todo, al final ha habido un pequeño cambio.
Hemos quitado a Olise y hemos metido a Ángel Di María.
Sí.
Creo que de forma merecida también podríamos haber metido a Leo.
¿Messi?
Sí, sí.
O si alguno tenía la duda.
O haber quitado a...
Leo Ortiz, ¿no?
Oye, pues me dio unos puntitos en el final.
Sí, sí.
Y también hemos metido a Ángel Di María.
O Leo Ortiz, ¿no?
Bueno, oye, pues me dio unos puntitos en el fantasy.
A Gildiz en el perfil izquierdo.
Incluso saliendo los pocos minutos que tuvo ante el City lo hizo bien.
Y a Igor Jesús en punta.
Sí, oye, Jesús que yo creo que es de Botafogo, pues junto a los centrales,
probablemente de los que más está destacando.
Además son sus últimos minutos con la camiseta de Botafogo, por si va a ir al Forest.
Pues este es el once ideal de la fase de grupos del mundial
y las primeras conclusiones que estamos sacando de este nuevo formato.
Gracias.